how the Chancellor Philip Hammond is
reportedly planning a budget raid on all
the workers to fund tax breaks for
younger people
one Whitehall source quoted in The Daily
Telegraph said he would unveil a bold
attempt to restock the deck for the next
generation the idea under consideration
is to pay for a cut in national
insurance contributions for workers in
their 20s and 30s by slashing tax relief
on pensions the government is being
pushed to address the issue of
intergenerational fairness by the tax
payers Alliance which publishes a new
policy paper tomorrow calling for
national insurance to be scrapped for
all young people let's speak to their
research director Alex Wyatt he joins me
now so Alex have you put a number on
this we've looked at a number of policy
options and what we would like to see
that the government do is to actually
cancel its plans to increase the
repayment threshold for student loans
because we think that that's something
that benefits disproportionately higher
earners graduates and instead our for
roughly the same amount of money about
2.3 billion you could exempt everyone
under the age of 26 from national
insurance so hang on you're still going
to pan tax cuts to you know people like
trainee lawyers and accountants
relatively well-off workers you may not
necessarily need a tax cut themselves
less though than you would by doing what
we're doing on what the government is
looking to do one on student loans and
actually we think that the subsidy for
student loans is extremely high and
something that government should be
doing a conservative government
especially should be cutting taxes
rather than increasing spending why have
you singled out national insurance
rather than income tax given that
they're they're more or less the same
thing I mean enough sources income tax
by any other name isn't it well they are
almost the same thing but long term we
would like to see national insurance
merge with income tax I mean though the
cost so to speak is roughly about the
same I mean penny on national insurance
is roughly about the same sort of
revenue impact as a penny on income tax
but in the long run we'd like to see
national insurance fully merged with
income tax so we'd like to see national
insurance come down rather than income
tax because we're not going to get rid
of income tax but we should get rid of
national insurance I mean the taxpayers
Alliance has always argued in favor of
Tax Simplification isn't this going to
make tax and national insurance more
fiddly if you're exempting certain
groups of workers from paying which is a
very very minor and hope
the temporary complication because it is
we see it as a stepping stone to getting
rid of the charge altogether and having
and having a full merger with income tax
and national insurance mean once upon a
time they were separate and national
insurance did have much more of a
contributing contributory principle to
it that's pretty much been eroded almost
almost completely now so we'd like to
see a merger in the long run all right
Alex Wilde from the taxpayers allowance
pretty the line Stephen appreciate you
joining me
get me allowances and me lines is mixed
up there